how did you know this one Justin was the
one um we went on Tick Tock and honestly
I was going through some crazy dark mess
in my life I was getting to know who I
was for the first time he didn't want me
like for my money he didn't want to be
around for the attention he didn't want
to be around for the clout was there
ever a point in time that you were
hesitant to get involved with this
family and everything that's going on in
his life sorry Mama Jane but I gotta
just give it to him straight not really
not it not at all you know um
well yeah but I know who she was but I
never really watched the show or knew
much about it
um but boy was I thrown into it yes you
were this is your first interview isn't
it it is it's my first one well welcome
to the circus let's talk about that
wedding y'all you didn't have not one
you had two weddings yeah so was this
one here was she a broadzilla Justin
oh sure who was she now so oh man it
just everything had to be I got cussed
out over sandwiches
Mama June's four daughters were all by
her side at the February ideas including
Honey Boo Boo who just made a splash of
the prom Alana is high maintenance I
mean she had a carriage yeah the horse
and carriage guy he came all over from
South Carolina like I told her if you
want to be different everybody rents a
car but who do you know gets a horse in
here yeah Honey Boo Boo that's it but
mama you your relationship with your
girls has been extremely turbulent it
has been up and down where does it stand
today
um honestly this season will show all of
that and when I tell people this you'll
have to think about that our show is not
a live show and that's where I have to
remind people that when you're watching
our show you're going to see starting
back in like October of last year to
where we just stopped filming like a
couple weeks ago but you're gonna see
all of that progress that me and the
girls have made to where me and the
girls stand today why did you decide to
give pumpkin custody of Alana does that
break your heart that your daughter
wants to say with your other daughter
um yeah yes and no because at the end of
the day we want to make sure that she is
happy is sugar bear in the mix right now
at all um Sherbert has not been in the
mix for quite some time I would like to
blast him but I'm not
I know well we do though have a lot of
talk about child support Jane are you
paying your child support very much very
much very much very much and more
because Alana is very expensive to take
care of she's disappointed me so much I
do Charlie I do we get to see more drama
in the new season of Mama June family
crisis which premieres tomorrow on WE tv
including in his battle with stage four
cancer next week she begins her third
round of chemo how are things going for
Anna right now she has a scan on
Saturday
we get the results back on the 9th which
is her first day of chemo this second
round has been really more rough on her
she lost all of her hair
um
and really honestly it's just been like
us we stay with her during chemo and
then pumpkin and Alana come up like one
day of the week and then Jessica comes
up so it sounds like your relationship
with Anna today is strong and you're
able to be there for her yes yes
um what can you inform us of the kind of
cancer she is uh adrenal carcinoma only
200 people in the world have it it's a
rare cancer it's very aggressive
um like one in one yeah she got
diagnosed
um how how it all like happened is in
September end of August she went to the
hospital with back pain she had a cysts
on her kidneys you got to remove that
night she had a biopsy it kind of five
she has stage two they claim they got
every bit of it out she'd have anything
to worry about it Flash Forward two
months later they said everything was
still out Flash Forward to January they
said there was a spot that they seen
Flash Forward to February
um when they she went to Atlanta doctor
when she got done she got diagnosed with
stage four cancer so it happened very
quickly
um it's in our lungs her liver her
kidneys and her spleen all on the left
side and it has
moved very rapidly and grew very rapidly
how are spirits
um just depends on what day it is like
all of us like honestly and she sleeps a
lot this round
her appetite is going you know she
doesn't want to eat some days yeah um
but I mean just like everybody like me
and like there's days that I don't know
whether to scream or get mad or get
angry or be happy or you know try to go
through the day but some days you just
got to put on that face and say hey how
you doing you know what I'm saying and
some of those days ain't those days you
know
um so as her mom and we've had to have
those talks that you don't want to have
with your child and
um
you know and so we've had this talk as a
family too so we all know what the what
the things are you know what her what
the end game is and we all are prepared
for that and I mean you're never
prepared for it but
um but I mean we know what could happen
you know and her children know that
which is sad because she has a 10 and a
seven-year-old her 10 year old knows
more of it than her seven year old my
heart hurts for you so much June yeah so
it's not an easy thing
so your sobriety Journey where are you
in that Journey right now um three years
of it's May three years three months and
like 15 16 days so like it's I don't
really like to count like the days or
the months now well it sounds like you
do well I mean I had to like think about
it because like people ask like the
exact time most of the time so like I
really have to think about it that day
but I mean it was January 27 2020 I
don't do anything like I have to be
Sober Sober like I don't drink I don't
do anything
um do people check in on you and do you
do drug testing um I do drug testing
every week
um and that's not
um for me to have a clear mind my own
self it's just something that is
required by honestly
um production that that's just a
requirement they require and that it's
just something that they've always
required I'm okay with that how long has
that been in place
um for the long time and I get that
um and that's just for their you know
sake of just making them
um feel secure for their their purposes
and but I tell them all the time that
those drug tests don't keep me clean I
keep my own self clean how are you on
your sobriety Journey I'm just like her
I'm over two and a half years clean
myself so we keep each other sober
really yeah people say that two addicts
can't be together but I disagree I think
two recovering addicts that are sober
can be together I don't think that one
addict and the other one sober can't
work you know what I'm saying but if
your boat's over and you both have the
same goals you can make it happen well
that's congratulations to both of you
way to put in the work and and to be
there for each other we do see Justin's
there for you you are sent to the
hospital this season so what's going on
with your health right now
um I mean I'm still fighting the
headaches on a pretty much almost daily
basis
um are they able to figure out what the
headaches are from exactly still really
not they've run a bunch of like testing
but honestly they don't know so you just
have to live for these headaches now
pretty much and like we're trying to
find the right doctor but the doctors
that I go to
um again because I'm honest that I am a
recovering addict
um I do get judged a lot but do they
think that it could be from the drugs or
do they think but I hope they're able to
figure out what's going on with you
right because it is frustrating at times
because I mean I can't think straight
I'll be asking him a hundred times like
where's my wallet where's my phone oh my
God don't let me forget to put my phone
up don't forget to get my credit card
yeah because you also are having
forgetfulness as well yes I mean that's
still happening today wow and you're too
young for that Mama June any questions
yes
thank you